>>> INSTAGRAM IS NOT REALITY.
WE KNOW THIS.
BUT THESE FOUR WORDS WILL BE AT
THE CENTER OF DEBATE ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA ON
MENTAL HEALTH FOR A DECADE NOW.
WELL AWARE OF THE ADDICTIVE
NATURE AND SELF-CONFIDENCE
ISSUES THAT CAN ARISE FROM APPS,
INSTAGRAM, FACEBOOK, SO FORTH.
GEN Z, THOSE BORN AFTER 1996
HAVE ONLY KNOWN LIFE ONLINE AND
ARE SUFFERING SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE OF THAT.
U.S. DATA NOW SHOWS A STARK RISE
IN RATES OF TEEN DEPRESSION IF
THE LAST DECADE, PARTICULARLY
FOR GIRLS.
BUT AS HAS BEEN WELL REPORTED
TECH COMPANIES KNOW THIS.
ACCORDING TO FACEBOOK'S OWN
RESEARCH, THEIR PLATFORMS MAKE
BODY IMAGE ISSUES WORSE FOR ONE
IN THREE TEENAGE GIRLS AND AMONG
GIRL WHO IS REPORT SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS, 13% OF BRITISH USERS
AND 16% OF AMERICAN USERS TRACED
THOSE FEELINGS TO INSTAGRAM.
JONATHAN HAIGT IS A SOCIAL
PSYCHOLOGIST WHO UNPACKED THIS
CORALLATION BETWEEN TEEN MENTAL
HEALTH AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
HE EXPLAINS WHY TEEN GIRLS ARE
MORE -- HE JOINS ME LIVE NOW
FROM NEW YORK.
JONATHAN, GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON
THE PROGRAM.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> MY PLEASURE, BIANCA.
>> LET'S START WITH THE FACT
THAT WE'VE KNOWN FOR A LONG
TIME, RELATIVELY SPEAKING, THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA CAN HAVE A REALLY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON MENTAL
HEALTH, BUT OBVIOUSLY AS EACH
YEAR GOES BY, WE GET MORE DATA.
WHAT ARE WE SURE OF NOW THAT WE
WEREN'T BEFORE?
>> SO, THERE HAVE BEEN STUDY A
LONG TIME, BUT PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
SCIENTISTS TEND TO HAVE A HIGH
STANDARD OF PROOF.
WE'RE NOT GOING PUBLISH
SOMETHING UNLESS WE'RE
CONFIDENT.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF STUDIES
SHOWING CORRELATION WITH THAT ON
MENTAL HEALTH, BUT SOME SAY, WE
CAN'T BE SURE.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS SHOW
THERE ARE LOTS OF KIND OF
EVIDENCE AND THE PREPONDERANCE
OF THE EVIDENCE DOES SEEM TO
SHOW INSTAGRAM IS CAUSING HARM
TO GIRLS.
>> AND WHY GIRLS IN PARTICULAR,
DO YOU THINK?
>> SO, ALL TEENS ARE GLUED TO
THEIR PHONES.
WHEN MY SON WAS 2, HE FIGURED
OUT HOW TO USE HIS iPHONE.
THE FACT THAT I DIDN'T BUY APPLE
STOCK BACK THEN, I'M KICKING
MYSELF.
ALL KIDS LOVE IT.
BUT THE BOYS AS SOON AS THEY GO
ONLINE, THEY'RE ON VIDEO GAMES
VIDEO GAMES PUT THEM ON TEAMS TO
COMPETE, WHICH IS HEALTHY.
GIRLS GRAVITATED TOWARDS THE
VISUAL, PRIMARILY INSTAGRAM, BUT
ALSO PINTEREST AND ALSO TIKTOK.
THE GIRLS GO FOR VISUAL THINGS
AND IT'S MUCH MORE ABOUT
PERFORMANCE.
IT'S NOT PLAY.
IT'S PERFORMANCE.
OF COURSE WOMEN, MEN ARE GOING
TO DO THAT, BUT 12-YEAR-OLD
GIRLS SHOULD NOT SPEND THEIR
DAYS PERFORMING FOR OTHER
13-YEAR-OLD GIRLS.
THEY SHOULD BE PLAYING AND
TALKING.
>> ON THAT SUBJECT, ONE OF THE
BIG CHANGES WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS, WHEN IT
COMES TO INSTAGRAM IN
PARTICULAR, WHICH ACCORDING TO
YOUR ARTICLE IS THE MOST
DAMAGING FOR ATTAINABLE GIRLS IS
THE SURGE IN FILTERS THAT AREN'T
JUST WEERLD EARS OR THINGS ON
YOUR FACE, BUT YOU CAN CHANGE
FEATURES, AMEND INSECURITIES YOU
HAVE ON YOURSELF.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
WE WERE FIDDLING WITH A SELFIE I
TOOK OF MYSELF AND THEN JUST
SHOWING HOW EASY IT IS JUST TO
SHORTEN YOUR NOSE, TAKE AWAY
BAGS UNDER THE EYES YOU GET FROM
WORKING IN THE NEWS, ET CETERA.
THIS IS SO EASY TO DO, AND HOW
MUCH DOES THIS CONTRIBUTE TO THE
POOR MENTAL HEALTH IN TEENAGE
GIRLS?
THE FACT THAT YOU CAN LITERALLY
PHOTO SHOP YOURSELF VERY EASILY.
>> YES.
THE ANSWER IS, WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH THAT IS THE CAUSE, BUT I
SUSPECT THAT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST FEATURES.
WHEN I WAS YOUNG, WE ALL TALKED
A LOT ABOUT HOW GIRLS ARE
SUBJECT TO SEEING AIR BRUSHED
MODELS IN THE MAGAZINES.
OKAY, BUT YOU KIND OF KNOW,
THOSE ARE STRANGERS FAR AWAY.
THE FACT THAT YOUR FRIENDS ALL
LOOK MUCH MORE BEAUTIFUL THAN
YOU, BECAUSE THEY LOOK MORE
BEAUTIFUL THAN THEY REALLY ARE,
MEANS MOST GIRLS FEEL BELOW
AVERAGE.
I THINK THE FILTERS -- MANY
GIRLS HAVE WRITTEN TO ME ABOUT
HOW SICK IT IS.
THEY CAN'T APPEAR UNLESS THEY
FACE TUNE.
I THINK ALL THIS TERRIBLE FOR
GIRLS.
GIRL GOING THROUGH PUBERTY, IT'S
THE HARDEST TIME OF LIFE AND WE
SHOULD BE PROTECTING THEM WITH
HARM.
BUSINESS MODELS THAT PUT THEM IN
COMPETITION WITH EACH OTHER.
>> EVEN IF WE'RE TOLD INSTAGRAM
IS NOT REALITY, CELEBRITIES AND
PEOPLE YOU SEE ARE EDITING WHAT
YOU LOOK LIKE TO MAKE THEMSELVES
LOOK BETTER, EVEN IF WE KNOW
THAT INTELLECTUALLY, WHAT IS
HAPPENING SUBCONSCIOUSLY IF
WE'RE EXPOSED TO THOSE IMAGES
ALL THE TIME, EVEN IF WE KNOW
THEY'RE NOT REAL, IT'S ALL WE
SEE?
>> I'M A SOCIAL PSYCHOLOGIST.
I LOOK A WAYS WE'RE SO TUNED TO
WHAT OTHER PEOPLE ARE DOING.
THE FACT THAT WE KNOW SOMETHING
CONSCIOUSLY, THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF BRAIN ON THE LEFT SIDE.
THAT DOESN'T MATTER.
KNOWING IT'S FAKE HAS NO IMPACT
ON WHETHER IT AFFECTS YOU OR
MAKES YOU FEEL ASHAMED OR PROUD.
WE'RE ALL VERY SOCIAL CREATURES,
ALL IRRATIONAL CREATURES, AND
THIS IS MORE TRUE FOR 11 AND
12-YEAR-OLD GIRLS.
>> IS THERE ANY CHANCE THAT
THESE STATISTICS WE'RE SEEING
NOW ARE SKEWED BY THE FACT THAT
GEN Z AND THE YOUNGER GENERATION
ARE MORE -- DISCUSSING THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH STRUGGLES?
ALTHOUGH MY GENERATION MAY BE
LESS LIKELY TO ADMIT THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH SOMETHING, BUT
TODAY ANY WAYER IS VA PEOPLE SAY
YES, I AM HAVING DIFFICULTY.
>> THE HUGE SURGE IN MENTAL
ILLNESS FOR GIRLS BEGAN IN 2012,
2013.
FOR THE FIRST FEW YEARS PEOPLE
SAID, OH, THIS IS JUST
SELF-REPORT.
THEY'RE SAYING THIS ON A SURVEY.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE
DEPRESSED.
WHEN I WROTE MY FIRST ARTICLE,BY
THOUGHT THAT MAY BE WHAT'S GOING
ON.
THEN WE GOT DATA ON THE HOSPITAL
SELF-ADMISSIONS FOR SELF-HARM.
GIRLS THAT CUT THEMSELVES FOR
NONSUICIDAL REASONS.
THIS IS NOT JUST THAT THEY'RE
SAYING THEY'RE IN TROUBLE.
THEY'RE CUTTING THEMSELVES AND
KILLING THEMSELVES.
AND THE RATE HAS DOUBLED.
IT'S UP MORE THAN 100% SINCE
2012.
>> WOW.
IRREFUTABL